tadié une personne à choisir pour être
confiné avec lui ou avec elle ce serait
hautement suis personne voilà vous dites
moi voilà je vis le confinement avec l
inconnu ou qu'en aucun cas connus ou
fois connu un pack terme aux boulangers
ouais bah ouais je sais pas vous mais
moi ce qui moi c'est rim qui récit prime
charisme et ouais je discute même pas
elle est sympathique je peux la demande
même le prolongement du confinement non
ah ouais quand même un responsable roro
il amoureux
je suis amoureux de cette femme brimée
jaune à thor fils n'ont plus qu'à passer
je vais vous dire vous êtes tout à fait
son style parce que son ex et fx
il a menti c'est vrai que là là c'est du
pareil au même moment pas que vous êtes
un mix entre eux tarek boudalia cachot
c'est ça cette fois ci vous lisent avec
quelqu'un de 2020 vianney non je les
adore ocb mois et demi depuis je connais
sa femme j'aimerais bien de consignes et
que toute la famille
alors juste regarder ce qu'on leur
aiguille vous êtes dans la maison toute
la journée aux fermes étaient pas là
je ne vais pas me dit papa tout sinon
joue son nom mais stéphane plaza c'est
ça mon rêve
j'ai fait les grosses têtes ce matin
avec lui il faut mettre des bouchons
pour les oreilles cassées sa gueule mais
on a une gueule très très très prennent
pas les amis les voisins et la plus je
suis pas dur que stéphane soit chaud non
moi non plus qui va quand même un peu
moi ce serait jean michel maire non
ouais sûr et certain mehdi directement
moi je suis sûr de moi il est gentil et
serviable
c'est sûr qu'ils me ramènerait le le
petit le p'tit dèj au lit parce que
s'ils ramènent le petit lait c'est
heureux
généralement c'est pas pour rien c'est
comme françois hollande sait qu'il a
cofondé un an
[Applaudissements]
quand même des gens ici monsieur
l'ordinateur
merci ça ça ça bien marié ça c'est une
technologie qui vient du mexique les
foules d'habitude chacun vous êtes ou
par exemple sont chez eux ou
mademoiselle qu'ils apportent à toulouse
où ça héros acquérant à côté de
montpellier à côté montpelliérain côté
il dit non merci merci mes chéris et
valérie benaïm ce sera avec qui vous ont
peut être fou oui obama barackobama com
en barrage alors prouver bush la baronne
barak tout sinon c'est quoi ce serait
génial parce que trouve qui les classe
on pourrait parler politique
géopolitique il raconterait plein
d'étoilés vraiment que barack obama ils
oublient va te faire chier
komara il va être là bas sinon c'est
5000 mhz alors est ce que pense pas il
paraît que lui moi je sais il paraît
qu'ils feraient être temps avec vos
intentions je sais qu'il faut mais bien
qu'ils vont ressembler beaucoup michelle
obama
vous ressemblez à michel wanna go c'est
tournez vous avec borat
non je veux ouvrir fendre la gueule dans
bright lights est ce qu'il est drôle au
quotidien moi je l'aï rencontré une fois
et a coulé il est très drôle a modifié
la première fois sacha baron cohen au
lycée monterait à marrakech du rire
d'abord qui est ça peut te [ __ ]
car à tout le monde parle de confinement
de corinne aller c'est quoi ces trucs là
bas ça ça vient ça arrive ça vient
d'arriver
ça n'arrivait pas olivier ferrand sur
tous les bons plans quoi je sais je sais
si on veut être confiné encore un mois
deux mois trois mois
excessif magasin
mais moi en fait je n'ai pas une
personnalité j'aimerais dédier un coach
sportif
oui c'est le genre j'aurais très envie
de doper mon endorphines tous les jours
envie de ça et là franchement bon départ
mais je remercie intelligent parce que
je m'y attendais pas we be 2 ouais je
pensais pas je pensais pas que ça on
peut être léger moi j'avais fait un truc
un peu mystérieux j'ai envie de me
remettre au chant et comme j'ai adoré
son dernier album je vais m car morgan
j'ai bien aimé son dernier album away
alors je propose c'est que la vanne est
tellement mal d'embûches et s'éteindra
clara et c'est vrai que j'adore clara
pour la danse pour cul voilà les
attendait pour amener dans l'absolu
comme ça rit franchement avec arthur